good job buddy you too brother
andy shane congratulations you've made
it into the final round
when you arrived here you used our tools
and equipment to forge signature blades
of your own design
now we're sending you back to your home
forges where you will recreate an iconic
blade from history
butterfly swords bad ass the butterfly
sword or who de dao
is a chinese weapon developed in the mid
19th century
short and slim two of these blades could
be carried in a single scabbard
their small profile also allowed them to
be concealed in a boot for the sleep of
a robe
the butterfly sword was forged with a
wide belly which made it an ideal
chopping weapon
chinese militiamen in the late 1830s
were outfitted with butterfly swords
which allowed for deadly close quarters
combat due to its versatility
it became a common weapon among many in
china including sailors
private guards and martial artists these
weapons are also
featured in one of the most popular kung
fu films of all time
the 36th chamber of shaolin good luck
we'll see you in five days
day two of the challenge have a lot of
goals today the d-guard is the main
focus this morning
[Applause]
i think i'll still round it a little bit
but that's the brass knuckles so
we want that to be able to put an
opponent out of commission
so after the d-guards we'll have to cut
some wood for the handles
african blackwood is a very hard dense
wood
it's hard to cut it's hard to drill a
hole in but it will take a nice finish
well i've got them dry assembled
i want to test these blades i want to
know they'll perform
the blade's hard it was chipping a
little bit because i had a pretty fine
edge on it
i'm going to have to change the edge
geometry still a lot of work left to do
i need to make myself a quench tank it
does not have to be pretty it just needs
to hold the oil
this is for making horses poop it's good
for quenching spring steel too
see this is really safe next to a
propane tank
come on freaking inferno here
that heat treat went very well for me
success
no cracks in those blades they're
straight they're true
and they are hard
but i want to test the strength of this
blade
a very short work of that it's time to
quit fighting and just get her done
day five i need to get the handles
sanded out and finished i need to get
the d-guards
sanded out and finished i have to
sharpen the blades and do a little more
testing
so now what i'm working on is the finial
nut this will cinch everything up tight
and when we glue it up
close only counts in horseshoes and hand
grenades it's a constant battle
[Music]
so that's the first time i've
encountered that that was a mess
i'm feeling a whole lot better now that
they are actually assembled
i'm going to build the handles today i'm
going to fit everything up i need to
make a pair of nuts that i can use to
cap the ends of the handle
it'll add a little bit of counterweight
and it will also
that'll just look cool father
ah holy sh
i knew that i would cut myself on these
blades before i was done and
sure enough i cut my thumb pretty bad
it's not a sword until it's drawn blood
so
right now painters tape and paper towels
will have to do the trick as you can see
my shop is very sanitary
so i'm not worried about it
where are my nuts
i can't have nuts that are too big and i
can't have nuts that are too small
my nuts need to be just the right size
could have just slapped the hardware
store nut on there but
decided to make my own hopefully this
will be the difference between bad ass
and
extra bad ass
man it's time for a beer for me
bladesmiths
the butterfly swords were designed to be
short swords because they were supposed
to be maneuverable in close quarter
combat and they were sharp
to test the sharpness of your blade i
will attempt to puncture slash and cut
the trifecta of sandbags sugarcane and
rope
let's see how well your blades do shane
you're up first are you ready i am sure
shane your blade moves nicely
it can definitely slash and thrust
through the sugar cane
it's sharp enough to cut at the same
time on the rope i can
shield and then cut the rope this sir
will cut good job thank you
andy you're up next you ready i'm ready
let's do this
good job oh smoked well andy definitely
you've got a nice point to puncture and
lacerate
on the sugar canes nice cut on my weaker
side
and to use the blade as a shield that
feels good so i can deliver my power
thrust
and it's sharp this sir
will cut good job thank you
bladesmiths this is the kill test the
butterfly sword when sheep appears as
one sword
but the minute you unsheath it you have
two swords to see how lethal your
butterfly swords are
i will deliver lethal blows on these
ballistic dummies
let's see how much damage your weapons
can do chain you up first you ready
i'm ready let's do this
[Music]
nice well shane the lacerations in here
will go
deep into the bone and break it at the
same time when you thrust it goes deep
into the bowels
and cuts everything inside on its way
out this sir
will kill great job thank you andy
you're up next
ready yes sir
nice andy the design of your blade
lacerated this ballistic dummy deeply
and that would puncture a lung and when
i thrust the weapon i completely
disembowel
this dummy this sir will kill
great job thank you
gentlemen your final test is the
strength test the butterfly swords
come from southern china now though they
were used by the military
primarily they're a civilian weapon now
to test the strength of your blades
we're going to take
six chops into this ice block now if
they're strong enough that edge should
hold up
shane you're up first are you ready i'm
ready all right let's do this
i've designed my blade so that they will
cut they will chop bone
i'm pretty confident in them all right
shane well your edges held up
beautifully
the weapon still feels nice and tight
and well put together what i do like is
the fact that i can hold this weapon in
one hand uh question for you
you only sharpen the two thirds of that
blade is there a reason the research
that i did said that only the bottom
third of that blade would not be
sharpened because of the monks
didn't want to kill somebody they would
want to thump them and not kill a person
i learned the same thing but it was when
you reversed it that that
so you don't put a finger on that edge
when you reverse that blade
nice design well done sir thank you sir
andy you're up yes sir okay
a little wet
your edges feel great feel fine i really
like what you did
with the uh fullering thank you a couple
of things
the back arms are just a little tight i
can't quite
get underneath that i like what you did
carrying them up there and putting that
detail on it though
but the biggest concern i have is i i
can't
i can't hold that as as one sword
i wouldn't be able to draw that cleanly
from a scabbard
generally though i mean they feel good
in the hand
it's a good job they held up well thanks
dave i see done
andy shane the judges have poured over
the details of your weapons and they've
made their final decision
andy shane you've both done some
outstanding work
in this competition there can only be
one forged and fire champion
and that champion is
shane congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion
good job thank you congratulations
brother
well fault battle bud absolutely of
course i would rather be
the one taking home ten thousand dollars
but i absolutely believe the judges made
the right decision
congratulations thank you shane made a
couple of excellent blades and
he deserves it this is andy holm over
and out
shane congratulations you are the forest
and fire champion and we'll be receiving
a check
for ten thousand dollars good job thank
you
i'm feeling wonderful this is the moment
i've been waiting for
the journey is the fun part you know i'm
very happy so what are you gonna do with
the money
i have a family that's sacrificed a lot
so we'll have a family council
and they will decide it's awesome
you